I heard you got into gaming
during this COVID lockdown.
I was I'm a workaholic
so my whole thing like
while everybody was picking
up hobbies, my whole thing
was to sit down and do
nothing. My therapist was like,
"Yo, you just need to chill
and find something that's not
attached to that you're
not trying to monetize."
I'm like alright, so I
started playing Call of Duty
and I got really into it,
like so into it that I bought
a headset. I didn't buy a
headset, I bought a headset,
like years ago and I just
found it in my house.
And I was like, "Oh, this is
what this is for, alright."
And so then I'm like, in it
at first, I wasn't saying
anything that's sort of
getting good. And I was like,
"Alright, yeah." I put
the mic down and it became
a real thing. And I thought
I was gonna hear a lot of
in words being thrown around
by children, but it was
way weirder than that.
The biggest thing I heard
was a kid, yo
(laughs)
As he was getting as he like
got a kill or something on
the game he was like,
"You didn't even get close
to eating my (beep)."
(laughing)
And, I was so confused. Like it was his
catchphrase, Conan.
"You ain't even get close
to eating my (beep)".
What kind of brag is that?
I don't know.
(laughing)
I took off the headset and I
just sat in my thoughts like,
"Yo, what is this kid's
life?" Like I don't what is
in what world. So he's just outside like,
"You want to eat my (beep)
but you can't though. I bet
you can't even get close!"
(laughing)
Which only means one day
someone would eat his (beep).
(laughs)
Yeah no, that taunt tells you
a lot, there's a lot going
on in there. I gotta remember
that. I gotta remember that
the next time I'm in an
argument with somebody
at a gas station.
(both laugh)
(indistinct) "I'm sorry
I cut you off in traffic"
"You just like you ain't even
close to eating my (beep).
(laughing)
(indistinct)
"Get away, this is where I live"
(laughs)